hospitals in Las Vegas in the area are
stretched to the limit this morning
treating the casualties Carter Evans is
outside University Medical Center of
Southern Nevada one of the hospital's
caring for the wounded it's about five
miles from the shooting scene Carter
good morning good morning just about ten
minutes away this is University Medical
Center the only level one trauma center
in the area you can see some activity
behind me with police officers
essentially blocking off the entrance to
the emergency room here making sure that
if any ambulances were to come that they
would have easy access also to keep some
of the crowd control here anyone who may
be coming to look for loved ones of
course they're very busy inside it has
been a busy night in this level one
trauma center they've taken in around
104 patients
thirty of them were treated in the
trauma center eight of them were taken
to the operating room 12 in critical
condition hospital emergency rooms
around Las Vegas they were filled with
victims delivered by an blintz but not
just that delivered by people in their
own personal vehicles today I heard
several accounts of that tonight people
who would find victims because the
victims in many cases were hiding and
they didn't know that it was safe to
come out they come out and there were no
paramedics around then it was just
civilians who were bringing them here to
the hospital we've heard many stories
like that of course you can imagine how
busy they are inside this hospital
tonight we've also heard that there were
a few off-duty police officers that were
in the crowd tonight that were injured
and one of them was killed in this
shooting so this hits close to home for
police as well but again at these
hospitals around here with 100 patients
in this level one trauma center 104
patients you can imagine it's very busy
inside right now
yeah it's very busy very sad in Las
Vegas today thank you very much Carter